[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle por natalia
cabrera esto es aquí américa el programa
donde revisaremos en profundidad las
historias y las noticias de nuestro
continente comencemos con los tres
países latinoamericanos que fueron a las
urnas en ecuador el nuevo presidente es
el conservador guillermo lasso quien
llegará en medio de una aguda
polarización las ganarle por el 5% de
los votos a andrés araus el heredero de
rafael correa aunque correa todavía
influye no fue suficiente y además la
segunda vuelta dividió a los grupos
indígenas en torno al correísmo
en perú las elecciones presidenciales y
el congreso llegaron en medio de una
crisis política y de una gran apatía de
los ciudadanos que están escépticos ante
la corrupción el empobrecimiento y los
repetidos juicios políticos y renuncias
en un país que ha tenido cuatro
presidentes en los últimos cinco años
olivia es una historia diferente porque
los comicios fueron regionales y
únicamente en los cuatro departamentos
donde se convocó a una segunda vuelta el
movimiento al socialismo de evo morales
está perdiendo en esas regiones y con
ello la mayoría de las gobernaciones a
pesar de que reconquistó la presidencia
en noviembre pasado comencemos entonces
con ecuador- la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales es el vivo
retrato de un país dividido a pesar de
que el ex presidente rafael correa sigue
siendo muy influyente en la política del
país y de que él corre y está andrés
araujo llevaba la delantera este último
perdió ante el ex banquero guillermo
lasso por menos del 5 por ciento de los
votos otra de las grandes novedades fue
la división del movimiento indígena como
lo explicamos en
nota rafael correa no está en el
tarjetón pero su presencia se siente a
través de unos fijados políticos
andrés araus quien se consolida como la
nueva cara visible del correísmo en
ecuador con el las ideas del ex
presidente siguen vivas y
particularmente la revolución ciudadana
que impulsa correa durante más de una
década correa tuvo un poder electoral
enorme desde 2006 cuando fue elegido
presidente por primera vez luego los
ecuatorianos lo reeligieron en 2009 y en
2013 para los comicios de 2017 no se
presentó un cuerpo propio pero apoyó a
lady moreno su vicepresidente y mano
derecha sin embargo moreno se alejó giró
hacia el conservadurismo y se acercó al
fondo monetario internacional- en esos
cuatro años desde la oposición
rafael correa enfrentó un juicio a la
distancia que en 2020 terminó con una
condena en su contra a ocho años de
cárcel por corrupción esto le trajo su
muerte política en el año en el que
aspiraba a ser candidato
vicepresidencial y ahora intenta
recuperar su influencia a través de
andrés araus la gran diferencia es que
los indígenas no apoyan unificadamente
al correísmo por el fraude que denuncia
a los candidatos ya qu pérez
el líder indígena que no llego a la
segunda vuelta presidencial en respuesta
la mayoría de grupos étnicos decidió
apoyar al voto nulo pero no todos
eligieron el mismo camino jaime vargas
presidente de la confederación que
agrupa a todas las asociaciones
aborígenes declaró su respaldo a rauch
pase lo que pase venga lo que venga
señora andrés araús economista
y me apoyo de todas las nacionalidades
de la amazonía ecuatoriana por otro lado
la excandidata pierna cedeño antigua
fórmula a la vicepresidencia de ya q
pérez se inclinó por el ex banquero
guillermo lasso aunque sostiene que es
un voto en contra del correísmo me
dirijo estudio las votaré por usted será
un voto antisocial del siglo 21 el
movimiento indígena pachakutik expulsó a
vargas y cedeño de sus filas así el
nuevo presidente de ecuador asumirá sin
tener el respaldo unificado de los
movimientos indígenas algo que ha sido
muy común en la última década
ahora hablemos de perú este es un caso
bastante particular en américa latina
porque las elecciones nacionales
terminan con un ciclo presidencial nunca
antes visto en sólo 5 años el país vio
pasar a 4 presidentes y ahora la disputa
podría ser entre el maestro de izquierda
pedro castillo y la derechista keiko
fujimori quienes irían a la segunda
vuelta en junio si el conteo de votos
continúa cómo va el contexto de esta
situación es una crisis política sin
precedentes en perú
cuatro presidentes en cinco años esa es
la crisis política que podría superar
perú con las nuevas elecciones generales
la historia comienza con pedro pablo
kuczynski el candidato que fue elegido
en 2016 tras vencer a keiko fujimori
pero kuczynski no ganó las mayorías en
el legislativo y los fujimoristas se
quedaron con el control de las cámaras
esto jugó en contra del mandatario
cuando los congresistas le hicieron dos
juicios políticos acusándolo de
corrupción aunque kuczynski superó el
primer debate en el segundo prefirió
renunciar antes de que el legislativo
votará su posible destitución
esta confrontación política ha creado un
clima de ingobernabilidad el entonces
vicepresidente martín vizcarra reemplazó
al antiguo mandatario pero enfrentaba la
misma oposición de los legisladores
fujimoristas las tensiones en reventaron
en septiembre de 2019 cuando vizcarra
disolvió el parlamento tan sólo unos
minutos antes de que los legisladores lo
suspendieran como presidente este choque
de trenes terminó con una nueva votación
legislativa y vizcarra se quedó en el
poder pero el mandatario no cantó
victoria por mucho tiempo el nuevo
congreso impulsó un juicio político
contra el presidente por el escándalo de
un contratista sin experiencia
vizcarra se salvó de la emoción pero dos
meses después el congreso le hizo un
segundo juicio político por supuestas
acusaciones de soborno en su contra y
esta vez la mayoría de los congresistas
optaron por destituirlo
hoy día
viejo palacio gobierno
me voy a mi domicilio
el ejecutivo quedó en manos del entonces
presidente del congreso manuel merino
pero de todos fue el mandato más corto
desde su posición se realizaron las
protestas más grandes que ha habido en
20 años los manifestantes consideraban
injusta la salida de vizcarra y veían a
merino como la representación de los
tradicionales partidos de centroderecha
el punto de quiebre fue la muerte de dos
jóvenes durante los choques con la
policía esto forzó a que el mismo
congreso pidiera la dimisión de manuel
merino tan sólo cinco días después de
haberlo nombrado presidente por último
llegó francisco sagasti con el objetivo
de seguir en el cargo hasta las
elecciones del 11 de abril para darle al
país un poco de estabilidad política
en bolivia el movimiento del socialismo
es el gran protagonista de las
elecciones regionales porque aunque se
quedó con la mayoría de las alcaldías
perdió las 4 gobernaciones donde hubo
una segunda vuelta si se consolida las
cifras esto dejaría al partido de evo
morales- con tan solo 3 de 9
gobernaciones a pesar de que ganaron las
presidenciales en noviembre veamos el
camino del partido más influyente de
bolivia en la historia reciente
el movimiento el socialismo ha hecho
campaña desde 1999 incluso en 2002 el
líder cocalero evo bonales se lanzó
infructuosamente a la presidencia un
cargo que solo consiguió a partir de
2006 cuando se convirtió en el primer
presidente indígena que tenía el país en
toda su historia
morales se nombra a sí mismo un
anticapitalista y un anti colonialista
en su gobierno volvió a bolivia a un
estado plurinacional que reconocía a
todos los pueblos indígenas y también
emprendió una campaña para hacer que las
petroleras y mineras quedaran en manos
del estado
unas 23 medidas
nada más casi todo están nacionalizados
médicas sin nada que nacionalizar
morales se convirtió en un personaje
popular con el respaldo suficiente para
ser reelegido en 2009 y 2014 y lograr
que el movimiento al socialismo
consolidar a su poder durante más de 10
años pero la gloria no fue para siempre
en 2016 morales intentó cambiar la
constitución para aspirar a un cuarto
mandato consecutivo y perdió en las
urnas aunque prometió respetar la
decisión en 2019 se presentó por tercera
vez consecutiva a las elecciones
presidenciales y todo cambio morales
ganó por un margen tan estrecho que
debía haber una segunda votación y luego
el tribunal supremo electoral actualizó
los resultados sorpresivamente y le dio
la victoria la oposición denunció un
fraude organismos internacionales
sugirieron una nueva vuelta y las
protestas se encendieron sólo cuando los
policías se sumaron a los motines y
pidieron su renuncia pacífica evo
morales- de un paso al costado y se
exhibió en méxico y luego en argentina
en su reemplazo del congreso position oa
la entonces presidenta encargada del
senado jeanine áñez una conservadora
ultra católica el más recuperó el poder
en las elecciones presidenciales de
noviembre de 2020 con el ex ministro de
morales luis arce ahora en abril de este
año el partido se afianzó al quedarse
con 240 de las 336 alcaldías aunque
perdió las ciudades principales como la
paz cochabamba santa cruz y el alto un
revés que espero remediar con la segunda
vuelta de los comicios regionales en
cuatro de nueve departamentos
al igual que bolivia perú y ecuador
chile también estaba llamado a las urnas
el domingo 11 de abril a una de sus
elecciones más históricas de la última
década pero finalmente el senado pospuso
la votación en la que los chilenos
elegirían a las autoridades locales y a
los 155 constituyentes que redactarán la
próxima carta magna del país el congreso
aceptó la propuesta del presidente
sebastián piñera de mover las elecciones
hasta el 15 y el 16 de mayo ante el
repunte de los contagios de kobe 19 es
así como la pandemia deja en vilo
durante un mes quienes serán los
encargados de escribir la nueva
constitución
ahora vamos al norte del continente el
presidente joe biden ya está dando
algunos de los giros que prometió en su
campaña presidencial sus primeros pasos
hacia el multilateralismo han marcado
una clara ruptura con la administración
de donald phau algunos ejemplos son la
reanudación de la ayuda económica a los
refugiados palestinos y la posibilidad
de regresar al pacto nuclear con irán
además eeuu ya volvió a la o ms como lo
explicamos en el siguiente informe agua
quiero decirles américa ha vuelto el
multilateralismo ha vuelto la diplomacia
a aguas y spark con estas palabras el
gobierno de hecho bailén anunció la que
sería su guía para las relaciones
internacionales de eeuu
hoy casi cuatro meses después el
mandatario ha dado varios cambios
importantes el primero lo hizo a pocos
días de llegar a la casa blanca cuando
decidió que eeuu volviera a la
organización mundial de la salud
otras dos movidas hacia el
multilateralismo ocurrieron en los
últimos días días ya que nada me
planeamos en reiniciar la asistencia
económica para el desarrollo y la
seguridad
humanitaria de eeuu al pueblo palestino
incluye 75 millones en asistencia
económica y para el desarrollo en
cisjordania y gaza 10 millones para
programas de consolidación de la paz y
150 millones en asistencia humanitaria
para la agencia de obras públicas y
ayudas de la onu con esto va a ir en se
aleja cada vez más de las políticas de
donald trump en cuyo mandato eeuu se
afianzó como uno de los mayores aliados
de israel finalmente la nueva
administración de bailén ha dicho está
dispuesta a negociar con irán y con las
cinco potencias que firmaron el acuerdo
en nuclear de 2015 aunque el gobierno de
bailén todavía no se ha comprometido a
levantar las sanciones contra los persas
está explorando la posibilidad de que
eeuu vuelva a suscribir el pacto del que
trump se retiró en 2018
y terminemos nuestro programa con la
imagen de la semana millones de
mariposas monarcas han encontrado un
santuario en mexico para salvarse de la
posible extinción y es que en los
últimos 20 años el 90% de esta especie
ya se extinguió en el mundo para
contrarrestar este proceso la reserva de
biósfera que está entre michoacán y el
estado de méxico recibe cada año a
millones de mariposas el sitio es tan
valioso que la unesco lo declaró
patrimonio de la humanidad en 2008
aunque la reserva sigue luchando contra
la tala ilegal y los efectos del turismo
masivo
[Música]
y así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa gracias por acompañarme en aquí
y américa recuerden que pueden seguirme
a través de las redes sociales que ven
en sus pantallas soy maría clara calle
por natalia cabrera
quédense conectados para más noticias
internacionales en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]